una tradición desde 1999 en las cumbres
climáticas que desgraciadamente cada vez
es más relevante el premio al fósil del
día una galardón sarcástico que entrega
la red de acción por el clima a los
países que más hacen para avanzar lo
menos posible en la lucha contra el
cambio climático el primero en recibir
este galardón en la Cope 27 fue Japón
por ser el país con el gobierno que
mayor inversión pública hace en
proyectos de petróleo gas O carbón hoy
sábado Cuando llegamos al Ecuador de
esta cumbre de cambio climático en
charmelsek el premio es para ha ido para
Estados Unidos gringolandia justamente
le han caído porque aquí en los
negociaciones están bloqueando todo sin
declarar muy bien con Claridad su
posicionamiento y sobre todo están
dejando de mover la mecanismo muy
importante para dar dinero a la gente
impactado por el cambio climático y cómo
se siente con este premio Es un honor
otro de los países que comparten el
mura son por ejemplo Rusia Egipto y el
próximo anfitrión de la cop28 emiratos
árabes Unidos